i already know who this one was this is
[ __ ] degenerate all right which one
jun
[Music]
life consultation after 10 years okay be
me guys
be me you sit there right i don't i only
know
right i don't know one thing right i
know the word orimo
right and i know i know it means incest
i know god likes incest for some reason
guys as i said before orimo isn't an
i open this thing don't worry you don't
have to it's literally
i feel like i understand the story of
the the anime
through this yeah which is very
concerning
because [ __ ] this is whatever you're
thinking about is probably what happened
in oremo
there is so many things in this anime
that made me like
push my desk chair back a little bit and
go like
all right yeah because this one i saw on
the list i was like oh i've never heard
of this one i'll i'll check it out
[ __ ] open up it's just
my one just because i read mine in
japanese yeah so my one just said june
england
jesus and i was like oh okay this one
you know sounds interesting
first page is literally just like kiruna
with massive teeth i'm like
yeah all right okay i knew
this one you did this your [ __ ] troll
didn't no no no no
no you [ __ ] dude don't tell me you're
like
this is to me probably the hottest
like series dojian i've ever read
what why
okay because like i purposely avoided
parodies
okay i this i i thought we i thought we
you know
because if that was the case i would
have recommended like three of my
favorites are all parodies yeah so this
was this is like the only
parody like parody dozen that is on the
list but like
i didn't know if we were avoiding
parodies or not yeah but i just wanted
to talk about this no matter what power
of the episode in future
and it's like because like most parodies
no parody dozens they last for like one
chapter they asked like
pages yeah it's like 10 30 pages yeah
yeah this this one last this one's on an
entire [ __ ] story
i felt like i was on like a [ __ ] like
big brother episode
like well this was just [ __ ] never
ended it just never [ __ ] ended not
gonna lie i can't we kept getting
[ __ ] weirdo yeah with this one with
this one okay admittedly
i i don't like orima like the show but i
think auri modogens are hot as [ __ ]
yeah all right but here's the thing like
this one
because it's because all the characters
are hot oh my god but here's the thing
right here's the thing with with this
particular one i've read a lot of
warrior moderations i've never read this
one
this one i was like okay first half i
was like okay this got kind of an
interesting story like
you kind of get to see like the
backstory of like the actual characters
it gets
[ __ ] weird and then second half like
she just like turns into a yandere yeah
so can you walk me through the story
like okay okay i had to
[Music]
so to explain the i guess i guess the
basic premise of orimo
as well so um so kierano
and kyosuke yep is the main the main
sibling pair
brother and then all you need to know is
also he has a childhood friend who i
don't
even remember her [ __ ] name uh the
glasses the glasses
the one who's the wife in this director
yeah yeah yeah yeah not mommy what's
what the [ __ ] her name
not to simmy or something oh look look
at look it up but but basically those
those are those are like all you need to
know
about the characters in this right so in
the ending of the original anime
um kierano uh kirito confesses to
kyousuke that which was like a [ __ ]
180 twist from like everything that was
built up before
right and then you know they have a few
dates together and then they decide
sister yeah yeah which you know they're
not blood related so
it doesn't count clearly
literally they can't keep getting away
with this they know you
they're like brother or sister not blood
related [ __ ] man
oh shut up connor look you recommended
mother's no
breasts that's literally a guy and his
stepmom that's just incest with an age
gap connor different it's different no
no no no no it's not
it's not she went into it it's a
different thing
it's illegal legally it's different it
depends
if it's like the stepbrother i don't
know i could be like maybe maybe
but no but this one's like we're
literally they're literally brother and
sister and this is literally just the
like the [ __ ]
card they slither in by the way like by
the way not blood related
god damn what the [ __ ] her name what
is that just just google just this was
just [ __ ] weird so explain
the story of this okay so i'll i'll
explain it
okay so this is this is like kind of
like a fan story
set 10 years after i got the understood
that yeah 10 years that's why i scored
10 years after consultation or something
like that right
um so this is set 10 years after the
ending of the anime where it has like a
slightly different ending
um so in this version um
kirino and kyosuke sleep with each other
right and
their family finds out and kirino just
gets [ __ ] banished right and they
don't see each other
for 10 years understandable banish the
[ __ ] out
parents doing what parents should do
exile your kid if they [ __ ] your sister
i guess
and so i guess this is set ten years
afterwards where she comes back
and um and they're both now married
he has married his childhood friend
which is like in the anime her like
minami is like
she's built up as like the plain girl
right she doesn't really have any
special things
all that will probably never win yeah
the girl that was never on the winning
list to begin with but she's she's built
up as just
the plane girl she's the childhood
friend right and
in this version he's the one that she
that she's the one that he ended up
marrying
and kirino has also apparently after 10
years married someone else
as well um and this is the first time
they've met
after 10 years and they think you know
they're
kind of like testing the waters to see
if you know they still have feelings for
each other
um they do and it turns out they do i
guess
test the waters with your brother and
sister to see if you still have feelings
together that feels like a very
dangerous game it's like russian
welcome to the incest tag bro literally
everything in this tag is that what if i
just like put my dick in your hand
let's just see if i get hard yeah that's
a good task
right okay so so to explain to explain
my tastes
right to explain
what i like why i why i thought this was
like
great because for one most parody
doujins they just like it's the most
vanilla [ __ ] storyline
like ever right it's just here's these
two characters
they sex you are watching it because
it's the characters you recognize but
this what i liked about this is that
it took the concept of warrior and it
like built on it and start like started
its own [ __ ] story
i do appreciate that element yeah yeah
it was like this is
this was actually a really story heavy
dozen yeah yeah i mean i
unfortunately couldn't really appreciate
that because i didn't know [ __ ]
anything about the show yeah
i was just like this [ __ ] crazy no yeah
no i did like the fact that it built on
the law
of the original series that it was based
off of but just it took like a [ __ ]
depressing [ __ ] oh it was [ __ ]
depressing yeah right
it's like like kirino turns yandere and
then like threatens kosuke and then
mommy me gets like like
yeah it's like it's like this this whole
thing just kept getting weirder and
weirder so you know be me i don't know
anything about this you know i don't
know anything about this series yeah
all i know is that he got banished for
[ __ ] his sister 10 years ago
and then they're like oh yeah we're
gonna meet again immediately [ __ ]
it's like no no like no [ __ ] downtown
of course just made eye contact we [ __ ]
it
of course oh she's like i don't even
love my husband i love you and it's like
oh jesus well it's because they both
know what they want right yeah
no words necessary and i guess like for
me if i were to explain my taste
what i find hot is like when a taboo
gets broken
right it's it's it's it's like it's it's
not
i mean it's not the incest okay i was
about to say i'm pretty sure that's the
one one reason every person who likes
the incest taxes
like what i hate about most incest
[ __ ] like most incest [ __ ] hentai
whatever
it's like it's like one girl says
oni-chan incest i'm like i'm just like
get that [ __ ] out of here you know
i don't give a sh i i don't give a [ __ ]
about it so you need the full back story
of their their brotherly and sister
yeah yeah you're crushed in front of
well it's it's it's it's not it's not
just between like
step siblings stepmother step sons like
i like you know
two two co-workers who know they
shouldn't get together they get together
that's hot like a teacher-student
relationship that's pretty [ __ ] hot
as well because it's
oh i understand though it's it's like
it's like what i find hot it's like
two p two characters who know they
shouldn't get together
but they're too like they're too hot for
each other to be able to stop it and
they do it even though they know it's
wrong
and i don't know man to me like breaking
it up breaking a taboo is [ __ ]
i totally get that i think that's hot as
well
but then there's the scene where she
just goes loon
like she just loses her mind for every
moment i thought maybe this could be hot
there's just something happened or i'm
like god damn it this is fine
that's so good like so there's this
whole
bit where he's having sex with the girl
yeah and
which goal uh we're getting there's only
two girls there's only two goals yeah
yeah uh the other girl
uh the boring one as you said yeah then
she pulls out just a strap-on for some
reason
it just comes out of nowhere and it
feels like if this feels like
it just felt like the dlc being tacked
on at the end
it was like you know you know what this
was so rushed in and half of like one
second and then it was never mentioned
again it was never shown again
just she just had it with her you know
what i was just ready to go you know
what i love about that scene with the
[ __ ] travels
where she like puts it into the wife and
she's like it's too big and he's like
this is the same size as my big brothers
so was he never i'm like was he never
serious with you and i'm like
oh my god that's a bird she just got
[ __ ]
burned dude this is the moment that like
really puzzled me the most
i just didn't understand why yeah so you
know he
he [ __ ] his step-sister or whatever
sister and has this whole thing and they
have this thing and he cheats on his
wife and they cheat on this wife and
they have this whole weird scene with
that
she [ __ ] the his wife and stuff yeah i
don't really get why that's happening
um but at the end she's like by the way
i told mom again that we fought and i'm
like why
why did you yeah what what about that
i completely forgot about that i was
just assuming i'm like did you really
need to just tell your mom that you
[ __ ] your brother again what are you
trying to achieve jesus is like what is
this
who does this i read that and i was like
well that was unnecessary
i was like well this just went too far
your mom is probably just
very nice let's be real got dragged into
this yeah your mom
didn't need to do that your mom's
getting to an older age you've got to
let her live her life peacefully knowing
that you were a good
saturday bt dubs mom [ __ ] my brother and
then just leaves
and then leave peace what's wrong with
you what is wrong with you why did you
do this
i just couldn't fathom it it's like it's
like you don't see this in the
you know when you go on [ __ ] i don't
know one of these porn websites bang
bros or whatever and there's the whole
mum versus
sun step
there's not a whole scene at the end
we're like okay son i'm gonna tell dad
now
you know that i don't i don't want to
see that [ __ ] don't include that chicks
i already feel guilty enough with this
[ __ ] don't include like this was
supposed to be depressing right
it's yeah it's it's meant to be a
depressing dosion really
it's like if it was like scat porn
they're like right let's do 10 whole
pages where they clean it up like
i don't know no let's not do that
get the bleach we'll clean this place no
i don't want to see this [ __ ] this felt
totally unnecessary
why was this in the story like you
finally had to wrap it up how does this
wrap it up in any way
to be honest to be honest like right
before
that whole thing happened no no right
before that whole thing ended in my head
i was like how are they going to end
this
and then do that and then that happened
i'm like well
i mean that's an ending game yes that
isn't it that's not the correct answer
okay the ending was a bit weird that was
it
only that was a bit weird